Exmark I don't know I just feel so
grateful it's been a gift I get to 12
years I've been a working actor for 12
years straight and that's kind of insane
in this industry nearly 1 million in
episode for a total of about 24 mil this
final season that's how much Jim
Johnny Kayleigh Simon and canal are
making for a little perspective that
paycheck is friends level money other
ways Big Bang is like the 90s sitcom
both cast supported each other to get
higher pay in 2017 the main cast got
about $100,000 knocked off their
paychecks so maíam and Melissa could get
raises to 425 grand in episode you
genuinely care for your friends oh and
remember how all the friend stars make
twenty million a year in reruns the Big
Bang cast will reportedly make 10
million a year in residuals alone at the
whole world gone mad yes things have
definitely changed for these guys life
before the Big Bang Theory immediately
before Big Bang I was in Wisconsin
studying plumbing I wanted to open up
design studio for bathrooms cause I was
doing a lot of driving around crying in
my car
out-of-work actor grind tutoring
neuroscience I was tutoring can Oh was
there something that you splurged on
when you said oh I'm gonna be here for a
minute no I mean I got like a sixteen
dollar cat litter scoop really you are
the best
[Music]
you